(energetic tune riffing)
- [Cassandra Freeman] People, people,...
- I love everything happening.
- You know what, I'm just
so ready for spring to come.
So, I was like, "Listen, make
me look like a sunflower.
Okay?"
(distant audience chuckling)
- [Kelly] Um, and so can
you tell us a little about
what's going on this season in Bel Air?
What's going on with your character?
- [Cassandra Freeman] Oh, okay.
So, Aunt Viv.
Listen, if you are a woman
trying to figure out how to
get your life to the next
level, really anyone,...
I feel like Aunt Viv is that story.
You know, Aunt Viv is so
great at giving you advice,
giving everyone else advice.
And this season the mirror
has to be turned around.
It's like, but how do you
move yourself forward?
So, the last episode, she
got kind of in trouble for
sort of standing up for
herself, saying like,
the Neiman Fellowship, this
artistic thing that she got,
is not what she thought.
Like, she doesn't actually
get to be creatively free.
It's so funny.
All she wants to do is be creatively free,
and nobody will let her be great.
Um, so this season you'll see like,
what does it take for you
to claim and grab the torch
of your own greatness?
And that means you have to
confront your own truth.
And that truth might hurt other people,
but it might set you free.
- [Kelly] But being honest
in the end is better for
the person, even if they get hurt.
I love a show that you love
and it's fun, and it's,
but you learn something.
I love that.
So wait, your father, I
actually found this interesting.
Your father, he was the
first black news anchor
in Jacksonville, Florida, right?
- That's right.
- [Kelly] How does that come about?
That's so...
I always look up to those people.
The fact that they can deliver...
Cause I've had to do really hard things,
like hosting things sometimes,
and talk about serious things.
And I, I cannot keep
that emotion in, like,
it just pours out of me.
I'm such an empath.
- Yes, of course.
- [Kelly] It's a talent to
be able to be on the news,
and have to deliver things that are...
I just have such a respect.
- Well, my dad, he kind of
fell into it accidentally.
My dad, very magnanimous, like 6'7,
his name's Mack Freeman.
He passed away years ago now,
like almost 20 years ago.
But my father actually, he,
it was sort of like a setup
with a civil rights movement.
And they were trying
to prove the point that
all of the, you know, stations
were basically racist,
'cause there were no black
people doing the news.
So they were like, "Mack, you go in there,
you try to sign up for a job."
So that's what he did.
He goes in, he tries to get a job.
My dad has two degrees, a master's degree,
political science.
Like he's a genius.
My, my father's a really smart man.
Who wouldn't say that about their dad?
And my dad, he goes in to
fill out the paperwork,
and they're like, "Boy,
we're not giving away
janitor positions."
And so he was like, "Got you."
So, my father starts to walk out,
and he says, "Hold up, maybe
we do have a job for him."
And so they made him an anchorman,
but it was really because there
was so much social unrest.
And they needed someone black to go into
the black neighborhoods.
So my father became very famous.
He was known as like Batman and Robin.
Back then you'd actually
have your own cameraman.
And so it was like him, and his friend,
and he became very famous as that.
But then I grew up being
this little girl that would
always introduce my dad.
And so it'd be like, I'd
be five and six years old,
and be like, "Hello, my
father is Mack Freeman,
and he's the first black
television news reporter,
second in the state.
And you might know him,
because he did this and that."
And so I started at such a
young age that it was never
a big deal to talk in front of people.
- I love that.
- [Cassandra Freeman]
Because my dad would be like,
"Yeah, when you're out
there there's nothing to be
nervous about.
They're hoping that you
give them something.
Inspiration, information, something."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- That's a that's a pretty cool thing.
Like a legacy.
That, that's a, that's amazing.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Well you're, you're carrying on
your father's legacy by
focusing on diversity
in entertainment as well, right?
- Yeah.
- I think that's so important.
- Yeah, you know, I wish there was a...
We need to create a
new word for diversity.
You know, it should be like
a word that means, like,
I want all my cool white friends to be
at the same table with me.
You know?
- Yeah.
- Like if you're sitting
around as an artist
in entertainment, sometimes
you might find yourself
in Oklahoma.
You're like, "Who's gonna
do my hair, and makeup?"
Or you're trying to shoot
a film in Tennessee,
"Who's gonna be the cameraman?"
Right?
And what happens to so
many of us is, what,
you just call up the people you know.
But what happens when even
the people you know are busy?
I like to think you come to
my company, Creatricity...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And Creatricity is like
LinkedIn having a baby with IMDB.
And IMDB is like the place
you go to find like where your
favorite actor and director is.
- Yeah.
- And so I hope that's what
Creatricity is for people.
It's just a force, an
easier way for integration.
I like to think...
- [Kelly] Like networking, right?
- Honey, it's networking, and
it's fun partying as well.
- Yeah.
(Kelly chuckling)
- You know, so you come,
and just think if you're
in a room with vetted media
entertainment people,...
- Yeah.
and so you don't have to be
like, "Why you here, Sugar?"
Instead it's like, "Oh, you
here, you must be somebody.
So let me tell you what
I'm up to right now."
You know, it should be easy to
make your idea come to life.
- [Kelly] Absolutely, without
getting so much friction
all the time,...
- [Cassandra Freeman] Yeah.
- or hurdle after hurdle.
- [Cassandra Freeman] Yeah, yeah.
And also, like, we get tired of, like,
collaborating =with the same
people over and over again.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Sometimes you need new energy.
- Well, you're just gonna
get the same product.
You might, you wanna
do something different.
Yeah, yeah.
- [Cassandra Freeman] Exactly.
Maybe something that no
one's even thought of before.
- [Kelly] I love that.
So, it's called Creatricity?
- Yeah, like the electricity.
- What a great name, yeah.
- Thank you!
- With creativity.
I like it.
- Thank you.
(distant audience applauding)
- [Kelly] All right, season
two of Bel Air is streaming
on Peacock with new
episodes every Thursday.